actress Simone misuk made history in
Marvel's Luke Cage as misty Knight TVs
first black female superhero she was a
badass she's now starring as judge Lola
Carmichael another badass and the hit
CBS drama all rise it's set in Los
Angeles courthouse the show is the first
primetime scripted series to produce a
virtual episode that reflects the
realities of the coronavirus so in
tonight's very special episode recorded
using FaceTime and zoom judge Carmichael
must preside over a virtual bench trial
during a mandatory shelter-in-place
order in the matter of the People vs her
fate oh I would have preferred you would
come to me with a plea deal yes you are
in judge Carmichael's chamber standing
right in front of her desk in fact okay
good to know and judge Carmichael is
very displeased with you - wait Talan is
this your first time appearing in front
of Judge Carl
[Music]
Simone misuk joins us from her home in
Los Angeles they were actually in court
room 802 good morning to you Simone let
me say this it was gift you and your
crew should give yourself a round of
applause I'm giving you a round of
applause right it was so creative so
well done so nicely executed so I have a
couple of things right off the bat how
did you guys come up with the idea and
more importantly how in the world did
you pull that off
so Greg Spicewood our show creator was
just trying to figure out how they could
come up with a finale you know we
stopped filming in the middle of our
second-to-last episode it was supposed
to be a two-parter and so our show
producers were trying to figure out how
we could give a proper farewell and at
some point Greg and I kind of joked
about how one of our characters could
work from home because she was pregnant
in real-life Ruthie and Myles and so I
said
everybody gets a little of what to do
from home it would be Shari and I don't
know what came first the chicken or the
egg but they came up with this virtual
episode I mean it was very much inspired
by everything that's going on right now
courts are happening virtually people
are all working from home and the
majority of you know the world and so
they came up with it they sent actors
equipment and things that they needed to
use during the filming but we all had
our own computers our own phones just
some lights and you know we just don't
have first in today well let me just say
mission accomplished but what was so
cool about it Simone is that you guys
had testing adult kids telling their
parents to stay home dealing with kids
in a meeting from home
toilet paper shortages exercising there
was one thing about a black man with a
mask who had a bandana on people
crossing the street which I've heard
actually is happening to black men in
this country and then you talk about
inmates in prison it was also relevant
all of the things that you hit on
talking too loud on the zoom which I
find myself doing so what are you hoping
people will get out of this there are
many messages in this show you know our
show tends to always try to be very
current and very present and one of the
things that I've noticed being at home
and binging a lot of TV everything feels
like it's BC before the coronavirus and
there's something about giving our
audience is a very present story that is
comforting that does show them how
fellow citizens are dealing with this
pandemic that they are not alone but I
think that it also does raise a lot of
important issues that we need to discuss
and consider as a society you know it's
very difficult to think outside of your
own situation you know taking care of an
elderly parent or if you're
immunocompromised or if you're out of
work but this also allows you to think
about the people in the legal system the
prisoners and the people who work in
essential industries who cannot take a
day off and so if this show like all of
our episodes just tries to open up
everyone's perspective to look outside
of themselves and to look at their
neighbor and see how they can help for
what it where they're coming from
there was also there it's I noticed a
thing it looks like a sort of a tie or
nod to DJ - dee-nice there was a DJ
played by Dorian misuk who was sort of
like the voice through the whole episode
about how people are feeling and what
they're doing what did you think of
during mystics performance did he do
okay on Instagram in order to raise
money first and yeah we should say I
should say that Dorian is your husband
he's also an actor we should also point
that out and I'm curious how you two are
navigating quarantine and it seems to be
going okay starting with that painting
that of the little girl on the other
side of your head I love her I love
[Music]
she's started experiencing yeah she
started experiencing she's okay the 15th
of March and she is now well home and
completely getting better and better
every day and you know it brought our
family closer I'm glad she's okay
zooom what happens is bringing families
closer together Thank You Simone thank
you and Bravo to tonight's show tonight
all rise 9:00 8:00 central on CBS